[Music]
okay everyone I am so thrilled today
because I am joined by Warren Amy and
Emily of the watchful eye on freeform
and Hulu how you guys doing today
I'm doing really good
um I'm so excited to talk to you guys
absolutely love the show
um my first question is actually for Amy
Amy with Tori do you get a little bit of
like a sick thrill playing a character
who can be pretty cruel to other people
in the show
yeah we had lots of fun moments or I
just got to be the meanest I've ever
been a guy laughing I just like walk
away in the middle of someone talking
and listen it's kind of uh really
um you know it makes you feel good I'm
not just kidding I got it out of my
system I guess good so it's got to be a
little therapeutic doing it I like to
hear that
um you know you do a great job at it and
then I was gonna ask Warren when you're
playing this mysterious character of
Matthew when you first read this script
did you feel like you got a grip on him
right away or is he kind of almost like
as mysterious as he is to the audience
in a sense well I feel like I got an
idea of who he was at his core which is
a father and like The Grieving and
different stuff like that but I mean
what drew me to this thing in the first
place is is just like you know Pilots
are tough man I mean you got to build
this world you gotta juice these
characters you gotta hope the viewing
audience clicks but then sometimes you
know
where are you gonna go with it and you
look at this pilot you're like oh man we
could go a million different directions
so that's what I found exciting about it
we introduced a lot of characters it
kind of just scratched the surface of
what they could be but because the
audience also knows whatever we're
talking about it it's a it's a murder
mystery because of the opening scene
like you don't trust anyone you
shouldn't trust anyone and to play with
it yeah for the whole series I mean
that's the best we love messing with
people right and we love to be messed
with as an audience that's the best yeah
100 and I love that the first two
episodes coming out like do a good job
of hooking in like you're saying and
make us want to know more and more about
this
um now Emily you have a lot of
experience writing on shows I want to
know now what's like the thing that
really stuck out to like the biggest
difference now being the showrunner did
you really like being a showrunner was
it a lot more pressure like how did that
feel oh I love being the showrunner I
get I I'm instantly drunk with power
I hate it's what's fun about it is
you're really you know someone once
described uh you know making a
television show as an octopus right it's
like you've got
so many different things going on at
once and they all have to work together
but they're all sort of like being
developed independently you've got you
know your wardrobe and the set design
and the props and the sound design and
the lighting and the you know everything
kind of needs to uh work together like
an orchestra in order to create this
environment and to create this world
that we have to believe in instantly
um and you know as the showrunner you're
kind of
um
you know you're you you to the degree
that you want to be you can get involved
with all of those decisions with all of
those like you know ideas and you can
sort of sit around and and and
brainstorm about like how would this
look and how would that sound and
um I just I I really really like getting
sort of that bird's eye view
um and also you know building the show
itself and the and the Mystery of it
just you know starting with the scripts
which is where everything starts um you
know that's that's great fun you know
ideally you're in a writer's room and
you can have one of those big walls that
looks like a beautiful mind with like a
zillion Post-its and red string and you
know uh we were because of coping
restrictions working on Zoom so we
didn't really have that
um you know we didn't have the red
strings and the Post-its uh we had a
virtual version of it which is right you
know it it was totally fine and great
and functional
um but you know building the mystery
work requires a lot of like
you know it's a it's it's it's a huge
puzzle and you know you have to reveal
something periodically
um without revealing too much and uh uh
it was definitely like a show that would
I would wake up in the middle of the
night with an idea and
you have to you know scribble it down in
the dark and then the next morning
wouldn't make any sense but you know it
just was all it got in my head like that
um and uh and it's and it's it's
it's fun and but you do you've made a
lot of decisions I mean that's that's
that show running is
yeah and I could tell with the answer
you gave too like how many things you're
thinking about which is incredible so it
shows like all those things you're
taking on children you do a great job so
I'm excited for people to just see your
work come to life now
Amy there are two great looking action
figures of you from Angel of Fred and
Illyria made way back in the day
um do you have these figures I wonder as
like just someone who's a fan of Buffy
and Angel like do you have them
somewhere just like in a little like
cupboard somewhere I do have this oh
this is great news
it gives them out to people as rap gifts
and she signs them
yeah right I knew it
Tori's getting I
was awesome oh there you go that would
be sick thank you
now you want a bunch of action figures
you just send them out to people that'd
be great
um no I love that's great to hear that's
just cool that's a geeky thing for me to
hear um and then Warren playing this
character that's dealing with
serious grief uh is it easy for you as
an actor to snap out of those kind of
dark places like when the camera stops
or you kind of still kind of got to stay
there
I mean it depends each role is kind of
different the interesting thing about I
find with Matthew is
I always imagined his his grief was off
camera he woke up you know he took a
deep breath got dressed and was like I
need to push forward for my kid and
cover up doing me so I think that's very
different than seeing someone on screen
constantly I mean there's moments and
we'll see the cracks in the in it all
and all those different things happen
but in general this is a guy who's just
kind of trying to push forward and and
do whatever he can so that his son can
heal his son can move forward I think
his own healing is secondary and I think
that's why he finds Elena to be such a
breath of fresh air I think he's just
like maybe this is it maybe we can
finally start to you know put the pieces
together because she connects with him
and she starts to bring him out a Jasper
out of his shell and so
um there's other times when you know
another characters were it's so much
that it's a hard thing to shake because
you're always you know you're trying to
live in a thing and we're just we're
emotional human beings and if you're
trying to tap into something there's not
always an off on switch so if depending
on who the actor is sometimes it can be
harder to let go of sometimes it's
easier but it just kind of depends
on the depth of what you're doing and
are you doing it in front are you
showing everyone that or is it something
you know that you're you feel this
character is doing quietly on the side
no for sure and that's that's a great
answer too and I like you mentioned
Jasper and just all the character
relationships that happen with Matthew
and I think that's what makes this show
so strong we'll stick with people is the
relationships in it so thank you guys
for joining me today and everyone check
out watchful eye on freeform and it's
next day on Hulu when it comes out on
Mondays I love talking to you guys and I
hope talk to you in the future thank you
so much thank you Steve